[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact it's used in
everything from soda cans to aircrafts
to smartphones it's light strong
corrosion resistant non-magnetic
non-toxic and naturally just
good-looking we're talking about
aluminum but if you live outside the
United States you call it aluminium this
is because the British didn't think the
elemental word aluminum was flashy
enough so they just added a vowel letter
I and they call it aluminium you see
shortly before aluminium was first
discovered in the early 19th century
because it was so difficult to obtain it
was considered among the most precious
metals on earth at that time it was
worth more by weight than gold or
platinum in fact because it was so
precious in 1884 the US government
commissioned a 9 inch pyramid of the
metal to use at the apex of the u.s.
Washington Monument at six point two
pounds it was at the time the largest
single piece of solid aluminum ever cast
soon after this research has found a new
method to extract aluminum from common
bauxite and the price plunged scientists
now know that aluminum is in fact among
the most abundant minerals on earth
making up about 8% of the world's land
mass perhaps a turn at surprises then in
the Bible when it says gold which is so
precious in this world will be as common
as asphalt in the new earth stay with us
friends were going to learn more on this
edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at
1-800-805-3030
and our co-host pastors Jean Ross
welcome listening friends to Bible
answers live and we do have lines open
if you have a Bible question or any
question regarding what the Word of God
says about living the Christian life
then we invite you to give us a call
that number 800 God says that's eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven one more time with your Bible
questions call now good chance get your
question on tonight's program 800 four
six three seventy to ninety seven and
God whoa yeah well seven lines open my
name is Doug Batchelor my name is John
Ross good evening listening friends and
past the Doug let's begin the program
with prayer your father in heaven we
thank you that we have this time when we
can open up the Bible and study together
and as always we want to invite the Holy
Spirit to come and guide our hearts and
our minds lead us loading to a clearer
understanding of the Bible for we ask
this in Jesus name Amen amen
pastor you open the program we're
talking about well a fairly common
material that is everything from as you
mentioned soda cans to probably
aeroplane parts lumina that's strong
that's light it doesn't rust and at one
time it was very very expensive of
course it's not that way now but it was
yeah the market fell out it was like
they say it was worth more than gold
because it was so hard to process and
once they found that it was very common
in bauxite and it could be extracted it
just became very common mm-hmm I think
most of the aluminum in the world comes
from Australia right now and it's
interesting there's several amazing
facts that I even left out of the
program about aluminum most of the
high-power electric lines that go around
the country they're aluminum
because aluminum is the best conductor
of electricity copper really is but it's
so much lighter if they use copper
they'd have twice as many poles holding
it up in the air because it's so much
heavier and so a lot of folks don't
realize that who was it the Wright
brothers when they first started using
aluminum in aircraft engines they were
afraid their competitors we're gonna
find out about their bright idea and
they painted it all black so they think
it was iron yeah but anyway it's an
amazing material one time thought it was
worth more than gold and now it's you
know we people throw him out the window
McCann's yeah oh one more fact I heard
about aluminum since we're talking about
it they said aluminum of course is 100%
recyclable I think it only uses about
15% of the energy to recycle aluminum as
it does to extract it from the earth and
they said two-thirds of all the aluminum
that has ever been produced is still in
circulation because it's been recycled
so I thought that was also interesting
but speaking of minerals and things that
are rare now that may be common later
you know the Bible tells us that gold is
very precious now but in heaven it's
gonna be a pretty common material you
can read in Revelation 21 21 and the
gates were of 12 pearls and each gate
was made of a single pearl and the
street of the city was pure gold like
transparent glass they say the reason
you see yellow in goal is because there
is a certain amount of impurities in it
and pure gold is almost looks like a
mirror it's almost transparent there was
actually a time in the Kingdom of Israel
when things were so prosperous that
everything was made of gold you can read
in 1st Kings 10 during the time of
Solomon this is verse 21 also and King
Solomon's drinking vessels were of gold
and all the vessels of the house of the
forest of Lebanon his summerhouse were a
pure gold
none were of silver silver was not
considered as anything in the days of
Solomon it was like stones and nothing
recycle riches then so what the Bible
says about gold shouldn't surprise
anybody I mean it happened once with
aluminum for us maybe our friends
listening would like to know more about
that
kingdom it is not just pie in the sky
by-and-by but this place that Christ is
going to prepare is very real and we
have a free offer for anyone that would
like to be encouraged by what the Bible
tells us about heaven the book is called
heaven is it for real and we'll be
sending that to anybody who calls and
asks the number to call is eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
that is the resource phone line just ask
for the book called heaven is it for
real I'll be happy to send that to you
or you can read it for free online at
the amazing facts of website just
amazing facts dot o-r-g if you have a
Bible question a phone line here to the
studio is 800 four six three seven two
nine seven that number again is 804 63
72 97 go to the phone lines our first
call is Jenna listening in Washington
Jenna welcome to the program hi hi how
are you doing pretty good
thank you and your question so my
question is how do I know that my
salvation is securing God well first of
all if you follow the invitation that
Jesus has given his promises that if you
come to him he will in no wise cast you
out and that if we renew our commitment
with Christ each day we can be sure God
is going to keep his promises and so God
keeps his promises you have faith jesus
said it will be to you according to your
faith if you believe his promises you'll
receive it and so you know don't let the
devil scare you the Bible says that he
that has begun a good work in you will
perform it and there's also promise that
God is the author and the finisher of
our faith now the key to winning the
race is keep on running if you slip and
fall don't stay down get up and and you
can read in the book of Hebrews 12 that
when you run that race you lay aside the
sin and the weights that slow us down
and you look to Jesus who is the author
and finisher of your
faith so I actually have a book I can
send you a free copy and it deals with
assurance how do you have assurance as a
Christian would you like a copy of that
sure all right well I'll tell you what
we're gonna give you another phone
number it's a free phone call just call
and give them your contact information
and we will we'll send you that book on
assurance the number to call is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven that is the resource phone line
call and ask for the book written by
pastor Doug on the subject of assurance
how we can have assurance that our sins
are forgiven that we part of God's
family so sure to call and ask for that
and we'll be happy to send them out to
anybody who does a next call he is let's
see we have Stephen listening from
Georgia Stephen welcome to the program
yes thank you Pastor this is something
this post will be for a while in for
Romans eight six eight because the
carnal mind is enmity against God this
is a person for that's not subject to
the law of God neither indeed can be
could you help me with that a little bit
yeah well there's two different
conditions that you find in the Bible
there's love and selfishness two
opposite motives there is the spirit and
the flesh now the Bible uses the words
carnal if you speak Latin or Spanish the
word carne means flesh I'll give you a
quick little tip in in ancient Rome they
used to have these terrible battles in
the Coliseum and there was all kinds of
death and bloodshed and gore and they
called it carnage and sometimes they
called it a carnival it all meant that
there was a lot of flesh and bloodshed a
carnival it because the word carne means
flesh so we've all got the animal side
of our natures and then we have the
spiritual higher part of our natures if
we live for the animal side like the the
bless of the flesh and the lust of the
eyes and selfishness we're gonna be lost
but if through the power of Christ we
subdue the flesh
and we live by the spirit walk in the
spirit then we can end up you know doing
the will of God it's only through the
spirit that we can do the will of God so
basically it's just the indwelling
Spirit of Christ that gives us the power
yeah I'm sure there's been times where
you know you thought well I feel like
doing this but I know it's not right and
so your spirit won over the flesh yes
Jesus never made a decision based on the
flesh he made its decisions based on the
spirit now you can be spiritual and know
when it's time to eat
you know you need food it's the
nourishment you can be a spiritual
person and fulfill the natural sexual
desires within a marriage and there's
nothing unspiritual about that but being
controlled by the spirit and going
against the law are being controlled by
the flesh and going against the law of
God that's sin well then when you had
when the flesh so to speak attacks you
then that's what so it was true normal
just appearing lovely on speech you know
think on these things so what we asked
we asked the Holy Spirit to give us the
power to to draw these thoughts these
kind of thoughts the spiritual thoughts
yes exactly when when Jesus was in the
Garden of Gethsemane and he was praying
intensely father if there's any way to
let this cup pass from me you know the
he recoiled from what he knew was going
to be the torture and mostly the
separation from his father but he said
look I want to do the will of God not
the lusts of the flesh in fact you know
a final good verse that we can do on
this is in first John chapter 2 verse 15
where it says love not the world neither
the things that are in the world for all
that's of the world is going to pass
away the lust of the flesh the pride of
life and the lust of the eyes but he
that does the will of God will abide
forever so we don't want to live life
carnally we want to live life
spiritually yes matter of fact God's
Word God's Word is his will yes
and one more verse I'll give you is
you look in if you look at the very end
of chapter 7 it says who will deliver me
from this body of death in verse 24 you
know we've got this battle between the
spirit and the flesh he says I thank God
through Jesus Christ our Lord
we're delivered and then it says we do
not chapter 8 we do not walk according
to the flesh but according to the spirit
just shall live by faith and that's it
sounds like yeah you've got it you're on
the right track oh we have a book called
life in the spirit perfect about this
very thing and we'll be able to send it
to you let's see we have Steven
just call and we'll be happy to send
that to you the number is 883 five six
seven four seven you can ask for the
book called life in the spirit and we'll
send it to anybody who calls and asks if
you have a Bible question a phone line
here to the studio is 800 four six three
seven two nine seven that's 800 god says
four six three seven two nine seven the
next call is Lewis listening in North
Carolina Lewis welcome to the program
thank you good evening and thank you for
your ministry how can we help you
tonight yeah you there okay good yeah my
question is in concerning comparing
Joshua chapter 10 and chapter 15 with
dear Jews chapter one was Bezique
possibly in the valley of ISIL on the
the flute let me see her go I'm going to
those verses again first he said go to
Joshua what is it chapter 10 yeah and
chapter 15 and comparing that with the
with judges chapter 1 the you note it
talks about the southern conquest of the
children of Israel after well the though
the battle at Gibeon with the five kings
mentioned in Joshua chapter 10 and then
in chapter
10 Joshua chapter 10 verses say 11 on
talks about going to deburr and musica
further down it says beth horon the Lord
cast down large hail stands from heaven
as far as a Zika right and then you're
wondering if that matches up with
chapter 15 well judges chapter 1 it
talks about the physique and how the
children of Israel had met him at
Bezique and he fled and you know they
took him to Jerusalem and in chapter 10
verse in judge in Joshua chapter 10
talks about how they pursued them as far
as azita and then returned to Gilgal and
if they were in a Zika and they went to
Gilgal juror Jerusalem would would be
open the pathway you know kind of on a
direct route and so I'm wondering if
Bezique was possibly in the valley of
agile on where the hailstones were were
cast down yeah now there's it says and
they found out an IB Zek in be Zack and
fought against him and they defeated the
Canaanites and the perizzites and Adonai
bees egg fled and they pursued him this
is a different battle and I don't think
Adonai B Zack is connected with a Zika
that you find in Joshua is that your
principal question now yeah I'm just
trying to place where well is iike that
they have done archaeological
excavations and they did find the site
that they call Ezekiel that's referred
to in Joshua chapter 10 at least and
it's got a modern name today apparently
after the Babylonian exile some of the
Jews went back and settle in that area
tell let's see the
today it's known as tells our carrier
that's te ll z a ka RI yeh if I want to
look at L always means he'll right yeah
my question is more towards the location
of where physique is though yeah you
know what you might find is do you have
any Bible Software no I don't do you
have a computer then other than just
online tools yeah well there's this and
some of the online tools are very good
there is a free program you can download
called East sword and there are
commentaries in East sword that are
really good what I do sometimes is I
just click on those and it actually has
atlases and you look at what the
commentators say about the places and
they've got some tremendous history and
you check out three or four of those
ancient commentators and you know I find
they're often just right on with the
location of those places got some maps
yep but that's a whole study you know
it's real hard on radio I'll just be
honest with you to help people visualize
maps right so we're saying places and
people are going to know where is that
but we're yeah that was I think the
southern part of Israel where the they
first entered the promised land from
well thanks for your call on next call a
is David listening in Texas David
welcome to the program well thanks for
having me on how are y'all today doing
great
and your question yes I was wondering
about first Corinthians chapter 11
verses 13 through 15
I've heard people bring up this chapter
before about you know women having
prayer shawls or veils or that type of
thing and and what I haven't understood
is I've never heard anyone reference
these other three verses I don't know if
you want to read it for their listeners
you're not sure let me say start always
start with verse 13 judge among
yourselves is it proper for a woman to
pray to God with her head uncovered does
not even nature itself teach you that if
a man has long
here is a dishonor to him but if a woman
has long hair it's a glory to her for
her hair is given to her as a covering
and then he goes on to say but if anyone
is contentious about this we have no
such custom nor do the Churches of God
know so my my question is when I've read
that I've always understood the covering
to be the long hair itself like in verse
15 and so when I read the rest of that
passage starting of course up higher in
verse you know three and four I've
always seen it basically saying if a man
has short hair that's okay but if he has
long hair that's a shame to him and so
long hair he shouldn't have his head
covered with long hair meanwhile as a
woman it does not have her head covered
with long hair she may as well be shaved
is what that verse six or something
so I've understood it that way and I
don't quite understand where people are
getting the you know the fabric in there
I guess because of the Middle Eastern
culture I suppose but well he I don't
know the idea was that when they came
into the presence of God to worship they
should come humbly and because a woman's
here was her glory that we ought to
cover our own glory so only God's glory
is seen now I'm just telling you what
the thinking was and so when a kid woman
came into a place of worship and
especially she was going to be praying
publicly or upfront she's never had
covered as a sign of humility because a
woman's hair was glorious and and
beautiful you know and women typically
their hair grows better than the head of
men and certainly lasts longer than most
men but and so this was just sort of an
ancient tradition and Paul was just
saying you know because we're Christians
in keeping with the customs of the the
Jews and even the Roman Empire it ought
to be a sign of humility now most of the
I'm sorry go ahead
oh yeah I'm sorry so so you wouldn't
keep wait long hair as the cufflink know
if you know well I've heard some read it
that way
but you know I don't think Paul would
write a chapter saying make sure the
women don't go in with their heads
shaved I think he was saying he was
going along with the idea of a woman
having her head covered there is a
couple of places you know we should be
careful not to build a doctrine unless
you have other verses there's one place
where it talks about Rebecca veiling
herself when she first met Isaac and
there are a few verses about veils and
so it was a custom in the east for women
to you know veil themselves and veil
their beauty when we came in to worship
God so men would not be distracted by
the beauty of the women when they come
to look at the beauty of God and so it
was you know this was a custom you don't
hear too many there are some churches
that are you know Orthodox that practice
this there's certainly nothing wrong
with it I think we need to be careful
about building the doctrine with one
verse there that's what I appreciate
you're a thank you I appreciate it next
caller Sharon listening from New York
Sharon welcome to the program yes I
would like to know what it mean in
Exodus 4 verse 23 to 25 all right I'll
read this for the friends that are
listening and I believe this is a story
when Moses is on his way back and it
says on the way to the encampment the
Lord met him and sought to kill him no
Moses is going back to meet with the
people of Israel then sapore his wife
took a sharp stone and cut off the
foreskin of her son and casted at Moses
feet and said surely you are a bloody
man to me and so he the angel let him go
then she said you are a husband of blood
because of the circumcision now the way
I've understood this and I'm satisfied
with his answer Moses of course he was
born a Jew and probably his mother had
him circumcised when he was 8 days old
she didn't put him up for adoption you
know I think he was three months old
before
the river and but when he fled into the
wilderness and live with the Midianites
they may not have been practicing
circumcision even though they were
distantly related to Abraham and Moses
failed to circumcise the two sons that
he had with Zipporah when he went to
Egypt he initially took his wife and at
least one of his sons had not been
circumcised they had had a family
argument about it she said this is
barbaric why are we doing this he said
it's the Covenant that God made with
Abraham while he was listening to his
wife instead of the Lord and God said
look you're the priest of the family you
need to do this and he kept neglecting
his duty and God stopped him before he
ever got to Israel so look I've called
you to do a great work among my people
how are you gonna be a witness among my
people if you're not even leading in
your own home and finally his wife said
okay you know you're a bloody man's and
Jesus is barbaric but she's circumcised
her son yeah I'm hoping he was young at
that time and then God said okay now
that you submitted to my covenant I'm
gonna let you go on with your mission
so that's the explanation that I've
heard that makes sense to me oh thank
you very much now could you help me out
with the word matrix matrix
yeah the word matrix there okay
it means the womb yeah it means the womb
and it they used to say whatever yeah it
means to come forth from and typically
it's talking about when a you know a
baby was born it even it uses whether
it's a goat or sheep it says whatever
comes from the matrix meaning out of the
womb of the animal the first that born
was to be offered to the Lord and at
least committed to the Lord
so yeah that's what their word and by
the way since you asked that in the
Bible you'll hear the word gog and magog
may Gog means from the matrix of God or
the children of God and there's another
place where you find that prefix used
hey I appreciate your question and maybe
with that call I should also remind
friends we still have lots of lines open
if you've got a Bible question good
chance you'll get on tonight just pick
up the phone and call we probably get
six or seven lines open right now any
Bible question we will do our best and
who do we have lined up pastor Ross you
know I think we coming out on break
Ramona I have time to take another one
Lynette for break oh you know what maybe
before we take another call well yeah
people can call in now we'll get your
call right after the break but should
maybe tell people about absolutely
something exciting happening starting on
the 4th of November from the East Coast
we do this radio program once a week
it's live it's on stations and satellite
radio across the country and other parts
of the world but most of what amazing
facts does these days is television and
we're on a number of major networks were
going to be doing a large program coming
from the Washington area the DC area
beginning on November 3rd it's called
foundations of faith right there after
the celebration of the great Reformation
we're gonna be talking about some things
Martin Luther was alive today he'd
probably be telling folks about a lot of
doctrines that have been neglected
foundations of faith you can go to the
website foundations of faith dot info
find more information there don't go
away
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
I really wanted to start a new
devotional habit but life got in the way
next thing I know we're a month into the
new year and I'm like what's the point
of starting then I saw 365 amazing
answers to big Bible questions each day
is a single study so you can start
anywhere on any day and not miss a thing
their crisp clear and enlightening get
yours today by calling 855-578-6767
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call
[Music]
welcome back listening friends thanks
for standing by those who have been on
the ride with us if you joined along the
way this is Bible answers live we do our
best to answer your live Bible questions
and we never know how the Lord is gonna
lead this program we just pray for
guidance we look at the word together
and lines are open if you want to give
us a call with Bible question 800 God
says that's 800 for six three seven two
nine seven one more time 800 for six 372
97 I am Doug Batchelor my name is John
Ross and be ready to go to the next
color we have Marjorie listening from
Michigan
Marsha welcome welcome to the program
you on the air thank you it's good to
hear your voices pastors like one well
thank you I have a question about
Gabriel visiting Mary and he explains to
her that she has been chosen by God to
have to conceive the baby Jesus and he
said that the Holy Ghost was going to
come upon her but I understood that it
was all three were going to be present
God and the Holy Ghost and Jesus in the
conception according to Luke chapter one
approximately around verse 34 it starts
and gives all three being present at
that time well this is talking about
when Mary speaks and she says how can
this be and the angel says that the Holy
Spirit will come upon you and the power
of the highest will overshadow you
therefore that Holy One who is born of
you will be called the Son of God you
know that is a great point you have
mention of the Holy Spirit you have the
Holy One which is Jesus the Son of God
born of the highest which is the father
all three are mentioned in that verse
yes
so what are you wondering does that mean
that all three were in Christ are all
three involved in the conception all
three involved in the conception well
all three are definitely in the verse I
don't know that that means they are
there's three separate but one well if
you want to look at it that way my point
is the minister that was talking about
this said that God was not available at
that time and I don't think he was right
he said the God was not visible at that
time right well the Lord appeared to
several people in the Old Testament I
mean you know Jacob said I've seen God
and I am preserved and Moses saw God and
Abraham saw God and they saw God
probably it's what they call it
christophany they probably saw God the
Sun his glory veiled no man jesus said
has seen the father at any time and the
spirit as a spirit he sometimes appears
as water fire wind and you know yeah I
honestly do believe that all three were
present at the conception of Jesus well
I have no problem believing that way
that's read you know I don't see
anything wrong with what you're saying
now the conception of Jesus would be
that supernatural moment that we it is a
mystery to us how God somehow the the
essence of God went into the the egg of
Mary and you know I even heard one
Christian Jewish scholar say that there
was a little bit of an artificial
insemination that happened that that God
also took something from Joseph because
why does it give thee why does it give
the genealogy of Joseph
it says the conception was he was also
of the house of David yeah he was of the
line of David so it is a mystery and you
know we've got to be careful not to be
too dogmatic about the Incarnation
there's two great mysteries that are
mentioned in the Bible one is the
mystery of godliness how God could be
incarnate in a man
the others called the mystery of
iniquity why man would want to be God
and the devil would want to be God no
but anyway we appreciate that good
question you've actually got me thinking
about something that you gave me a verse
for another debate I'm doing and I
appreciate that I mixed Coley's Peet
listening from Arizona Pete welcome to
the program yes hello
hi Pete how you doing hi I'm doing fine
how you're doing great
what's your question okay my question is
I've seen several of these movies like
Passion of the Christ and all of those
and and all of the other life of Jesus
movies and they've mentioned how excuse
me how the rope that Judas hung himself
with was the rope that was around the
donkey's neck that Jesus rode in on is
there any wing to that or any meaning or
is it just something that's a that's a
yeah that's a that's a colorful
tradition that has been repeated there's
not a shred of Bible evidence other than
you know legends that came hundreds of
years after the Bible there's not a
shred of Bible evidence that says
anything about the rope that was around
the donkey and the rope around Judas I
think it would be very interesting to
try to piece together oh and what
difference would that make
you know I guess some people are trying
to make a point that Judas made a
donkey's decision but yeah there's
there's no Bible truth to that there's a
number of interesting legends you'll
have legends about Barabbas being
converted and and they make movies about
it but there's nothing in the Bible that
says that and I don't know pastor Ross
if I've never run anything talks about
the rope around the donkey and the noose
of Jesus so I don't even think it says
he used the word noose doesn't appear
just as he hung himself so we don't know
what he used hurt himself with sheets
okay so yeah the one thing the one
follow-up commentary is in the book of
Acts chapter 1 Peter says that whatever
Judas used to hang himself broke and he
fell a must
hung himself from a high place he fell
and it was dashed on the ground it
wasn't a pretty print shirt but
something like Jezebel fell out the
window
Judas fell anyway hey thank you very
much for your question Pete next call is
cliff listening from Florida cliff
welcome to the program yeah thanks for
taking my call
yeah my question is and the New
Testament talks about the new covenant
will be based on better promises why is
to say that the new promises are based
on that the law is now written on our
hearts versus okoma is written on stone
and because now it's been on our hearts
that we will have a willing desire to
keep the commandments as we grow and
deeper live with the Lord you know it
will flow from us naturally versus the
old covenant keeping the law was more
out of fear and obligation versus now
it's out of love and yeah well do the
right reason to keep the law has always
been love you know if you look in the
Ten Commandments
it says and I believe it's the second
commandment pastor Ross where it says
showing mercy unto thousands of them
that love me and keep my Commandments oh
right in the Ten Commandments is the key
love me and keep my Commandments but a
lot of people haven't gotten that they
didn't get in an Old Testament time and
you probably know legalistic groups that
don't get it now Jesus when Jesus said
you know the two great Commandments are
love the Lord and love your neighbor
Jesus was quoting the Old Testament you
read in nineteen lava dick is 19 18 it
says that you should love your neighbor
as yourself and you read in Deuteronomy
chapter 6 you're to love the Lord with
all your heart mind soul and strength
and so loving the Lord and loving your
neighbor our Old Covenant but the when
he talks about the better promises what
you'll notice the big difference is when
God gave the children of Israel the Ten
Commandments they made a promise the
nation said all that God said we will do
we will do it well they didn't they were
trusting in their own strength then you
get to the New Testament and God says
the New Covenant is I will it won't be
based on your promise it'll be based on
my promise I will put my law in your
hearts instead of you saying we will God
says I will and that's the better
a promise of God is infinitely better
than the promise of people and of course
the new covenant is actually predating
to the old covenant if you look at it
the first reference of the change of
heart is found all the way back in
Genesis where God says I'll put him
between thee and the woman between thy
seed and her seed and that is the law
written upon the heart God made a
covenant Israel but they didn't trust in
him to keep the law they said well we
gonna do it on our own and that's why it
failed yeah what were you saying that
that makes a lot of sense I mean that
Jesus is the better promise because he
kept along we can't so that answers that
question but the follow-up so what does
it mean then that he writes the law in
our hearts so what does that mean for us
and as I just mean that to me that means
like it was written on our hearts we're
gonna as we grow and deeper love with
the Lord we're gonna just have a greater
desire to you know he said if you love
me you will keep my Commandments I was
weak exactly when deeper love you know
we'll have a desire to want to keep them
not so unlikely oh gee I gotta keep the
team and commandments out of some
obligation there's more to love yeah
well you know we still want to keep the
law and keep in mind I think I heard you
say something well we can't keep it it's
true we've all sinned but I believe that
the Bible says through Christ all things
are possible
and so when he puts his law in our heart
we can do what would otherwise be
impossible so I you know I mean not in
the heart right there when it's in the
heart you know I don't know too many men
they're gonna tell their wives you know
I know I promised not to commit adultery
but I can't keep the law not too many
wives will accept that they're gonna say
you better keep the law so you know
there are things that God can change our
hearts and I praise the Lord I see you
know use drugs and drink and and God
changed me and I praise the Lord but the
love is what keeps the promise this
keeps there's a bit of ire to keep the
commandments there's right to love
basically exactly that okay you know
what we've got a lesson that really
spells us out it is a tremendous lesson
anyone that wants to better understand
the relationship between the law and
grace we've got a lesson called
in stone we'll send you a free copy if
you just call the line and I'm gonna
call his 808 three five six seven four
seven you can ask for the study guide
called written in stone it's actually
part of a whole series of lessons that
the amazing facts has and you can enroll
for free into a an hour right there when
you call you can enroll in a Bible
School and we'll be happy to send you a
number of lessons dealing with important
Bible truth
the number is 885 six seven four seven
just ask for the study guide called
written in stone if you have a Bible
question a phone line here to the studio
is 800 four six three seven two nine
seven eight hundred four sixty three
seventy to ninety seven annex holy is
Stephanie listening from New Mexico
Stephanie welcome to the program thank
you very much for taking my call yeah
thanks for calling you know it's ironic
the caller previous to me my question
was basically similar in first John
chapter two 3 through 6 where it talks
about if we know him we will keep his
commands he says I know him and does not
keep his commands as a liar the truth is
not in him but whoever keeps the word
truly the love of God is perfected in
him by this we know that we are in him
he who says he abides in me ought to
also walk as he walked and then and so I
might I have this one area where I'm
just not I don't have self-control and
I'm sinning and so then it takes me to
Matthew 7:21 through twenty three where
it talks about not everyone who says
Lord Lord shall enter the kingdom of God
and how he'll say he never knew you
those who practice the lawlessness
so I'm so like I don't want to be one of
those people who is told I never knew
you because I do love the Lord and I and
I do strive to keep his commands and be
obedient and walk the walk and not just
talk to talk but there's that one area
you're struggling yes don't yeah I don't
want to be the one that's told I never
knew
well uh I think that first thing you
want to know is it is possible for you
to do what God asks you to do God will
help you do what he wants you to do do
not grow weary in well-doing the Bible
says as long as we're in this body in
this life there is going to be a
struggle with sin and temptation you
know praise the Lord in the new earth
we're not going to have that struggle
but there is gonna be a battle Paul said
you know I fought the good fight I
finished the race I've kept the faith
there's a there's a battle he said we
wrestle against principalities and
powers in heavenly places is a wrestling
match there's a fight and so don't be
discouraged sometimes you fall in the
battle believe that God can finish what
he started in your life when you sin
don't become comfortable and say well
that's just my weak spot and accept it
repent and tell the Lord if you fall
again don't get back up repent again
this is place in the Bible where it says
God cast Seven Devils out of Mary
Magdalene and I don't think he did it
all at one time it makes it sound like
seven different times she fell and so
you know the Bible says a righteous man
may fall seven times yet he rises again
so don't get discouraged you know what I
tell people is Stephanie I struggled
with smoking I mean I used all kinds of
different drugs I'm not gonna brag about
but for me smoking was the hardest thing
and yeah I quit smoking so many times
it's like Mark Twain said quitting
smoking is easy I did it a hundred times
I quit smoking so many times and then
I'd go back and I'd get discouraged and
then I quit again I went back and I quit
again I went but I threw him away and I
then go take him out of the garbage can
and and it was a struggle and went on a
long time a couple years and finally by
the grace of God I threw him away 40
years ago and I never had another one
that once and so don't quit quitting you
know what I'm saying you'll be so happy
when you hit the victory I know I keep
striving I'm like that
whatever six or eight were talks about
oh yeah you know what you want to do the
thing you don't want to do exactly
exactly
don't forget don't forget what Paul then
writes in Romans eight I praise God now
that we get the victory through Jesus
Christ we no longer walk after the flesh
but we can walk after the spirit and so
continue to pray for that victory and
and I think God will encourage your
heart you know say we got a book that I
think you would appreciate if you just
call an aster it's called tips for
resisting temptation and is something
that we can all benefit from we'll be
able to send that book to you all you're
left to do just give us a call on the
resource phone line that number is 885
six seven four seven and asked for the
book called tips for resisting
temptation at number again is 800 eight
three five six seven four seven annex
Coley's Larry listening in California
Larry welcome to the program Larry you
there I am how are you doing great and
your question tonight my question
tonight was about suicide and what would
you like to know well I want to know
what the Bible says about it my wife of
almost 20 years 11 years ago committed
suicide because she was under depression
she was a alcoholic and other things you
know she had a behavior that was I'm
trying to kind of think of the word here
she kind of up and down bipolar yes she
was bipolar I didn't find this out
except through a friend of a friend
whose wife was bipolar and she told me
that woman told me that yeah the only
reason I decided to live was because I
had two kids so she made the decision to
break through the crust of the the
government what I'm trying to say the
the well are you wondering anyway can a
suicide be saved is that your question
my question is yes can assume I assume
you saved all right now that's an
important question there's two ways I
always like to approach that question
one is I think there will be people who
went through you know tremendous mental
trials they may have been under terrible
duress from physical suffering and they
took their lives they were not
themselves at the moment and because God
looks on the heart and he considers the
circumstances you know you have someone
that maybe committed their life to the
Lord they love the Lord but just were
overwhelmed in a moment of weakness or
may have been chemical imbalances that
we don't understand and they took their
lives and you know I think we've got to
be careful not to close the door and say
they couldn't be saved but then there
are people who are listening right now
that think you know I have thought about
checking out so many times and me
personally I Statoil with suicide even
as a kid and the teenager you need gets
so discouraging you get their hormones
going up and down and and the little
problems you think the whole world is
crashing in around you and I I
frequently thought about suicide and one
of the things that kept me from it is
just my curiosity I thought I might miss
something tomorrow but for a person who
believes you've got to realize that
suicide is out of context with God's
will if it's a sin to commit murder
well that would include murdering
yourself and it probably would not bode
well for a person if the last act of
their life is self murder and if a
person gets discouraged and you're a
believer anything go if I just commit
suicide then you know I'll be with the
Lord well actually what you can do is
lose all your options and seal yourself
in a very bad situation so you wake up
in the wrong resurrection and you're
permanently lost so you know where
there's life Solomon says where there's
life there's hope and that's in
Ecclesiastes and so I would
say that can't a person who committed
suicide be saved I believe there are
cases where that will be the exception
but a person should never presume to do
that because under most cases it
represents hopelessness and fate they've
lost faith and without faith it's
impossible to please God so it's a
difficult question I hope that helps a
little bit and make sense Larry and we
do now I wrote an article on this if you
if you go to amazing facts and type in
Doug Batchelor suicide you'll probably
see the article I wrote on this and it
may give you some more verses and we
appreciate your call
next kohli is Cheryl listening from
Minnesota Cheryl OH Michigan rather
Cheryl in Michigan welcome to the
program hello hi and your question oh
well I am wondering about what happens
when you die but specifically since it's
a huge topic
what about angels you know you hear oh
they escort you to heaven but if you are
really actually going into a state of
dormancy where you'll be resurrected at
the Second Coming or then you know the
angels aren't where they escorting you
to or are they just there for comfort or
are they always there or is that not
even biblical all right you got a great
question yeah I can have pastor Ross
look something up for me he'll send
forth his angels to gather together is
elected I don't remember if that's
Matthew or Luke or Mark there are three
places where Jesus talks about a second
coming the Bible does say that the Lord
will descend from heaven with a shout
this is first Thessalonians chapter four
and the Trump of God and the archangel
and the dead in Christ will rise now if
all of us have guardian angels I believe
at the resurrection those angels they've
mark the spot where you know we last
were and they'll be there to join us in
the resurrection and escort us up to the
Lord
yeah it's actually two references the
one is Matthew 24 verse 31 token of
Jesus at the second coming and he'll
send his angel
with a great sound of a trumpet and they
will gather together his elect from the
four winds from one end of heaven even
to the other and then the same thing is
also said in martini 1327 yeah and so I
think the angels are involved in the
second coming both for the living and to
as an escort if you will the resurrected
so yeah the the idea that people are
resurrected and one by one the Angels
carry him to heaven first thessalonians
says we go to heaven together we're
caught up with them together and we go
to the glory but there will be angels
there okay thank you i what about the
presence of angels at that moment just
before final death being you know at
your bedside I guess that could be your
guardian angels or yeah there's you know
there are a number of places where in
history people who were believers that
were dying said they could see angels
and I have no reason to doubt that I
believe angels were around us all the
time the Bible talks about Moses when he
died and it says God buried him well God
probably used his angels and angels were
there of course guarding the weight of
the tree of life so having angels nearby
when believers passed away I think that
they were around the cross when Jesus
died we shouldn't doubt that they would
be around believers when their breathing
their last yeah like trying to think of
some verses I can't think of how many
but we there's no reason not to believe
that I think you know what mostly
prompted my question is and and I've got
total answers thank you I'm very
satisfied but is the idea that of this I
think many people you know this thing is
being escorted and I think that comes
out of the blink of the eye and you're
going to be oh well the resurrection
will seem like great this twinkling of
an eye for us in a moment the twinkling
of I will be transformed so we have time
for one more
question I'm looking at the interview if
we have a quick question let's see who's
left all right we're gonna Anthony New
York Anthony we got just a few moments
in your question this evening hi good
afternoon my question has to do with
someone who is a Christian but lately
they have made the decision not to
celebrate Christmas not to celebrate
Easter not to celebrate the resurrection
because the city's holidays are speaking
holidays all right well let me I've got
to get to an answer we're gonna have to
cut you off so let me give you an answer
real quick on that first of all we got a
book we'll send you a free copy and it's
called baptized paganism there's nothing
wrong with a believer wanting to
celebrate the resurrection there's no
command to do that there's certainly
nothing wrong with a believer wanting to
praise God or remember the birth of
Christ
while Jesus probably was most certainly
not born the 25th of December there's I
think a lot of Bible evidence it was
more like the fall there you know if a
person wants to focus on some of the
pagan trappings of these things there
there is some history where these things
were connected with you know the spring
solstice and the the winter solstice but
you know that's where you use Romans 14
if you're going to regard a day regarded
to the Lord hey I apologize we had to
make your questions so short Anthony
we're about to go off the air listening
friends we do have a couple of final
announcements I want you to hear don't
forget to tune in to our special
foundations of faith meetings that are
beginning on November 3rd 3abn Hope
channel amazing facts TV go to the
website amazing facts Arg
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
life's a curious thing I mean just when
things seem under control
wham you're hit with something new your
marriage is good
suddenly it's on the brink of divorce
that job's great and then it's gone and
so's your life savings you feel healthy
Danny a doctor gives the bad news what's
coming next you could look to the stars
but they don't have the answers but this
does the prophecy Study Bible by amazing
facts
this Bible special its 27 personal study
guides lead you on a life-changing
journey through God's Word to discover
real answers to life's questions from
health and relationships to family and
the future the hopes in here get your
amazing facts prophecy Study Bible today
by calling
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF ag0 RG and sign
up for our free Bible study course and
make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore com which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word
to take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 RG did you enjoy this
program make sure to tell your family
and friends tune in next time for more
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]